un 49,3 encore un le 11e en 10 mois pour
la première ministre Elisabeth borne
aussi
que carrelage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 un article de
la Constitution créé en 1958 mais
d'abord à quoi ça sert certains
l'appellent l'arme nucléaire législative
l'article 49-3 il consiste à faire
passer un projet de loi sans le vote des
parlementaires
Premier ministre peut l'activer le 49-3
permet d'accélérer un débat jugé trop
long ou de contrer un blocage de
l'opposition sous la Cinquième
République il a été utilisé 100 fois et
certains chefs de gouvernement n'ont été
très friands allez voici le podium sur
la troisième marche Edith Cresson 8,49.3
à égalité avec Raymond Barre et Jacques
Chirac mais elle n'est restée que 10
mois Matignon
[Musique]
faute de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
elle a utilisé le 49-3 pour faire passer
plusieurs projets de loi dont le budget
1992 ou encore la création de l'Agence
du médicament
nous sommes obligés de recourir aux 49,3
après Edith Cresson en seconde position
Elisabeth borne 1149.3 en seulement 10
mois
elle a notamment dégainé le 49-3 pour
faire passer le projet de loi sur le
budget 203 sur le fondement de l'article
49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution et sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement et sur la plus haute marche
du podium le grand gagnant est Michel
Rocard c'est lui le numéro 1 du 49.3 28
à son actif en 3 ans à Matignon
j'entends faire mon métier dans le calme
dans la sérénité dans les côtes de
chacun
louper aussi sans majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée il a enchaîné les 49.3
notamment sur le projet de loi de la
création du Conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel conformément au troisième
alinéa de l'article 49 de la
Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement ou encore le projet de loi
de programmation militaire Michel
roccart tire au gros calibre le 49.3
depuis 1958 seul si Premier ministre
n'ont jamais eu recours au 49-3
[Musique]